learn Fong and her girlfriend Amanda
weeks have recently relocated to the
castle sediment Lauren and Amanda would
team up with Murray Singh and provide
invaluable support and experience
towards the fish farm and aquaponics
operations
however following the attack on the
White House it was discovered that
Lauren had been taken away along with
Murray
what are the Black Tusk trying to gain
through capturing these personnel
[Music]
during a catch-up Lauren would tell many
of the hardship they are going through
at their current settlement so many
offers a solution
everything okay
sure we lost some people this week but
we're keeping it together as best we can
sorry to hear that
sorry to say it
you need anything
honestly
a new place to live it's a little
crowded around here but I'm working on a
solution
it's not ready yet but it's safe and
warm and if you don't mind living in a
construction site I could send a team to
movie tomorrow
sounds perfect thank you Manny
Manny offered to locate Lauren and her
girlfriend Amanda to the castle
settlement to give them a safe place to
live and help rebuild
as with anyone during these times Lauren
and Amanda would be given jobs to help
keep the community functioning everyone
needed to do their part if these
settlements were going to survive
Amanda
she reads lips right
yeah but I can translate
you sure you're up for this
Amanda says I'm deaf not dead I can feed
the fish
of course sorry just some of this stuff
is weirdly Technical and not sure how
good I am at explaining any of it
we all have to start somewhere if we
mess up we try again
right okay cool sorry I just
I've never worked with a deaf person
before
I'm totally messing this up aren't I
we're used to it
so how long have you girls been working
together
three years
were you our interpreter at school
she was my tutor before I got the Nerf
to ask her out
all right I didn't realize you were
lovers
Amanda wants to know how old you are
40. why
she said she must be older than she
looks if she called us lovers
oh
I'm totally messing this up
seriously it's fine just maybe we're
sick to the work instead of the small
talk
I don't think you're good at the small
oh my God I am not a people person
what did she say
obviously
it was really Amanda's idea this is a
genius
explain how it works again
to provide some shade in the summer and
reduce heat loss in the winter we've
made these rafts out of foam the roots
go directly into the tanks and feed the
plants making it easier to harvest
what's the substrate for the plants
rock wool inflation sounds on that in
abandoned construction site
figured there wasn't enough to inflate a
new project but it was perfect for this
it's like a proper hydroponic Farm
Amanda says
technically Hydro requires additional
chemical inputs
this is a closed system so we have a
proper aquaponic grow operation
where did you learn how to do all this
before the green poison we were talking
about starting an urban farm after
graduation
the original plan was to grow tilapia
and salad and do a food truck
that's amazing we're really lucky you're
randomly assigned to this project
it wasn't random we asked Manny for this
assignment
oh
you didn't tell me that I think this
might be his idea of a joke
we really need to work on a sense of
humor
it turns out that Lauren and Amanda had
requested this work detail and that they
have some good experience in aquaponics
which is basically a system where waste
produced by farmed fish were other
aquatic creatures supplies the nutrients
for plants grown hydroponically which in
turn purifies the water
so for a fish farm this is fantastic for
filtering the water but will also
provide another source of nutrition
through the plants being grown
it's not it's just going to take a while
that's fine
we started the cardamom seeds last week
we should be able to harvest Greens in
another week or two but it'll be a
couple months before we have seed pods
ah thank you
I've never heard of green cardamom seeds
being a pregnancy craving is that an
Indian thing
oh I don't want to just eat the pods I
want to make Karma
oh that makes more sense
thanks again
and please keep this to yourself or not
out of the lids yet and I've miscarried
before so I'd rather not have to have
those conversations if it happens again
I don't want to put Manny through that
understood
okay that's funny
well that's funny Amanda said her lips
are sealed
thank you Amanda
and thank you for figuring out how to
grow the cardamom
you girls really are the future
this is obviously earlier on before Mari
had told many that she was pregnant
sometime in the first three to four
months of pregnancy but we can see that
the girls have been working with Murray
for a little while at this point as
Murray seems to be picking up a bit of
Amanda's sign language
agents receive Intel that Lauren might
be in the Midtown East District of
Washington DC
their first destination is the Fallen
Crane's control Point currently under
the control of the Black Tusk
their numbers were huge but the agents
came prepared
using their Aces and eights build they
were also rocking the ridiculously
overpowered determined Talent on their
Marksman rifle they must have been
feeling particularly lazy that day
after clearing the compound they
intercepted a hostile comms
my old office
I already purged the records they have
my batteries that's after something and
she's not sharing what that is
[Music]
these comms revealed that Vikram Malik
and Lauren were being taken to the odia
tech office
with no time to waste the agents swiftly
set their course and move out on their
mission to rescue Lauren and vekram
arriving at the office they find a small
contingent of black task soldiers
guarding the entrance
after making quick work of them they
climb a ladder making their way into the
building next door and navigate through
to the tech office via the balcony
window
here there was a much larger
concentration of Black Tusk but this was
no problem for the super broken One-Shot
body shot Talent
once the leader on site was eliminated
another hostile comms was recovered
Lauren has been relocated to the MLK
Memorial Library
next stop the agents will be going to
the Eastern side of the district with
the black task of set up an outpost at
the library
[Music]
the agents wasted no time plowing into
the guards defending the facility
eventually jtf backup would arrive and
provide a much needed distraction while
the agents managed to find The High
Ground
it wasn't long before the Black Tusk
commanding officers had been taken down
and the site was under their control
retail store we're closing in honor
fortunately they were too slow Lauren
has now been moved on and has been
spotted heading towards the odia retail
store
in the northeasternmost part of the
district agents push towards the front
doors of the store
after clearing the Black Tusk they
noticed the entrance had been barricaded
however they found a way through the
service door below
the black task on site was taken by
surprise and it wasn't long before the
high value Target made itself known
after absolutely murdering the target
Manny's voice could be heard over the
earpieces
you got the target nice
making their way to the stronghold the
agents took a few moments to assist the
heavily fortified entrance
once satisfied with how they were going
to approach the situation they wasted no
time in taking out the Black Tusk units
on site and proceeding through the front
doors
Lauren's been working with Murray
running the aquaponics
bringer here it's almost like Sokolova
took our people to run parts of her
operation
pushing through the compound eliminating
countless hostiles and other enemy
communication would be intercepted
the only reason to convert the card
greenhouses with need to do an aquaponic
separation like we have at the castle
the garden says filtered water and
recycle it back to the fish
Lauren's their prisoner but it sounds
more like she's advising the black
tuscum running an aquaponics Workshop
what the hell's going on here
the agents continue their Relentless
Advance battling through room after room
facing a hold of Black Tusk soldiers
accompanied by the warhounds
the agents were unto turd making precise
shots and effortlessly dispatching
enemies left and right
as they push deeper into the library
they come face to face with the Black
Tusk commander who joins the fight
but the agents had stupidly lost all of
their Stacks shooting a piece of
equipment on the ground so it meant that
they actually had to aim during this
encounter
is falling apart
very unsecure
once eliminated many announced that he
is sending someone in to bring Lauren
back to the castle
although I wonder why the agents could
have done it I mean they hit it there
anyway
once Lauren was back in the castle many
would see how she was doing
I wasn't helping them
we heard you talking to them about the
gardens oh that
they asked me a question I wasn't
helping them I was just answering their
questions Mac attract hostages were not
supposed to openly antagonize their
captors if they want to stay alive that
makes sense
what was changing tactics aligning with
the true Sons
infrastructure
this isn't a short-term solution if
they're setting up basis in local food
security they must be getting ready to
build a stronghold for winter can I go
now I really like to see my girlfriend
yeah sorry apologize to Amanda for me no
need and don't worry we'll get Mari back
I don't know where the medical team took
her but I'm sure she's fine medical team
yeah when they first captured us the
medical team took Cindy and Mari Vic was
freaking out but I'm fine so I'm sure
they're fine
Lauren disparately attempts to get away
from many hoping to reunite with Amanda
however many driven by the need to
uncover the truth behind Lauren's
cooperation with Natalya and the Black
Tusk
annoyed and cornered Lauren finally
gives her reasons
many listens intently and recognizes
Natalya's long-term plans including the
need to secure sustainable Food Supplies
if they were to succeed in taking over
though many finds it hard to believe he
tries to understand the situation
considering Murray's safety and
well-being in the process
much like the last two Lauren was
treated pretty well by Natalya in the
black task
while I'm pretty sure no one is buying
this many seems to be a little bit
confused however we'll give them the
benefit of the doubt he's worried about
Mario after all so he's probably looking
a little deeper than needed
there may be something to be concerned
about here if we peer this com-up with
the last one where Murray was talking
about her concerns around having another
miscarriage it shows that Murray's been
having these fears for months now
she would have these fears anyway but
given the state of the country these
concerns would obviously only be more
intense
things are a lot more dangerous for
expectant mothers and their babies at
this time
so when you hear in this piece that
Murray and Cindy were taken away by
medical personnel and that Vic is
freaking out about it
it was right after they were captured so
hopefully it doesn't actually mean
anything is wrong instead this could be
just to show Murray everything they have
how set up they are to be able to
provide any medical care she should need
we need to remember the image that was
given to the season when Natalia is
standing over the top of the Personnel
who were captured in a puppeteer sort of
way
is this the way Natalia is going to gain
Murray's loyalty by using Mario's fears
about her baby and its future
even when we rescue her she's still
gonna have the same concerns
Is it alive is it healthy is the birth
gonna be okay
Natalia has a lot of the things that
Murray needs to feel safe so how will
this impact the community going forward
will this drive some sort of divide
and what does Cindy have to do with any
of this
Lauren Fong was a super minor character
from a side mission quite a while ago
and now she and her girlfriend Amanda
play a big part in helping Murray with
the fish farm
we finally learn of what Vic was doing
when we first found him there he was
purging the records for Natalya
if you had forgotten who Vikram Malik is
I'll quickly re-jog your memory
very early on there was a side mission
called odia tech office
the division was tasked with securing
some new battery packs for the theater
settlement
once inside the office they found a
civilian called Vikram Malik he worked
for a deer tick and he was being held
there against his will by some hyenas
the agents rescue Malik but the
batteries out there the place had been
completely looted
Malik agrees to help the division by
locating some new battery packs and
meets them at the odia retail store
he needed to gain access to the computer
in the store to find some files he
needed
stay in the office Malik directs the
agents to the basement
while down there he triggers the alarm
gaining the attention of all hyenas
within a two block radius
melick had set them up and after
escaping the building he was never seen
again
we later find out that had been fired
from the company prior to the division
rescuing him and while we were helping
him out he took the time to go ahead and
delete the information being stored on
the servers
well now we know he was doing it for
Natalia
but this time during this Rescue Mission
he has no idea where he's been sent back
there
Vic suspects that she is sending him
there for something else but he has no
idea what
anyway we have the fourth and final
Target coming up so hopefully we'll
learn a little bit more when we finally
rescue Murray
thank you very much for watching and
extremist malice extreme remedia
[Music]
[Applause]